first tattoo I got was this little guy
right here
it's a based on this book that my whole
family read everyone's got it on their
wrist and it was right before I really
had any tattoos and so I wanted to make
sure that it wasn't visible and so I put
it down here and basically it's about
this seagull who wanted to be more than
just a seagull
it's Jesus right here but once again I
didn't have any fake tattoos so I didn't
want to put it somewhere and have it
visible yet because the world didn't
know I was getting tattoos I was only
like 17 my favorite tattoos probably my
new one
I really like this one took about three
and a half hours almost four hours and
the worst part about it is that it'd be
like this for so long and it was just
been uncomfortable this one means a lot
to me it's my mom's eye this is my mom's
birthday seems like I have a lot of
stuff to do me and my dad got this one
together this is a G it's for my boy is
his daughter's name Georgia she has a
brain condition and so I got that for
him just to support him I don't know I
got his back this is a signifies wisdom
X means unknown you know there may be no
my Michelle of me or might know the
artist would not necessarily mean this
is my ex-girlfriend so I kind of try to
cover her face up with it some shading
but people still know
I can't really say I feel lower back
tattoos I'm male or female I think David
Beckham has a little [ __ ] stamp that's
no good
oh this one's really cool story behind
this one is uh it's ll stands from my
head's low to lift it up just to never
keep your head low and always look for
the better Daisy so this was me hanging
out on my GQ cover shoot thank you so
much for hanging out with me what else
those are my tattoos and